An hilarious Edna and Jack-Jack scene and
a return to Syndrome's island are just some
of the scenes and stories that ended up cut
from Incredibles 2.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm revealing all the deleted scenes
and stories you never got to see in the Incredibles
sequel.
If this is your first time here, be sure to
subscribe to get all my Pixar videos and also
leave a comment about the movie for a chance
to win a cool Incredibles 2 Funko Pop.
Spoilers ahead, so take care if you've not
seen the film yet, or add this video to your
Watch Later playlist.
A fantastic fashion show scene featuring fan
favourites Edna Mode and Jack-Jack was originally
going to appear in the Incredibles sequel.
In the deleted sequence, Edna hosted a fashion
show of her designs that Jack-Jack hilariously
and repeatedly interrupted.
The clothes in Edna's fashion line, called
"Mode", were worn by models but still drew
inspiration from the powers of Edna's favourite
clients: Superheroes.
For example, the see-through chiffon around
this model's head was inspired by the look
of a force field.
Of course, we know only too well from the
first movie about Edna's disdain for supermodels:
"Spoiled, stupid little stick-figures with
poofy lips who think only about themselves"
"Feh!
I used to design for gods."
So, the fashion show was really a way of showing
that Edna was having to work with models because
Supers, who she really wanted to work with,
were still illegal.
Incredibles 2 is Pixar's longest film to date
and I think this scene was cut because the
movie was pretty packed already.
Although we do get some fantastic moments
with Edna and Jack-Jack in the final film,
I'm sure many fans would have liked to see
them together even more!
An earlier version of the story that was eventually
discarded featured Helen donning a disguise
of a black wig and glasses, and taking on
the fake name Gina Stryker so she could go
undercover and return to Nomanisan Island.
There was a mystery on the island that she
needed to figure out and this could have been
an interesting alternate story especially
if it had uncovered some as-yet-unknown secrets
about either Syndrome or Mirage who were both
based on the island in the first movie.
The scene where Elastigirl uses her powers
to stop a runaway monorail, while simultaneously
dealing with masses of traffic and a family
phone call, was initially going to be a lot
less action-packed.
Yes, an early version of that sequence had
Elastigirl bring the train to a halt by simply
pulling a lever after she'd broken into the
control room.
I'm really glad they explored other options
for that scene as, if they'd gone with the
initial idea, it would have been a lot less
adrenaline-fueled and we wouldn't have seen
as much of that awesome Elasticycle chase
sequence, which was a very cool moment of
Elastigirl displaying her solo superhero powers.
The opening sequence with the Underminer went
through many changes during the movie's development.
At one time, it was going to feature enormous
clay golems bursting out of the ground, then
that idea was thrown out and they tried robots
instead, and even massive earthworms!
All those scenarios ended up being scrapped
in favour of the runaway tunneler because
the idea was that the sequence should work
like a cold open.
It was meant to quickly grab our attention
and get us on board for the rest of the movie.
And all the additional golems, worms or robots
could have dragged the scene out too much.
Another aspect of Incredibles 2 that was altered
numerous times was its villain because it
just wasn't working.
That caused some pretty big headaches for
the filmmakers especially when the movie's
release date was moved from 2019 up to 2018,
which meant they had much less time to try
out different scenarios to discover which
one worked best.
Incredibles 2 writer-director Brad Bird also
had villain issues on the first movie, which
had a different big bad before Syndrome.
However, Incredibles 2 was an even tougher
nut to crack and Bird reckons he discarded
"two and a half movies worth of scenes" along
the way to creating the final villain plot
with ScreenSlaver!
Initially, actor Bob Odenkirk's character
Winston Deavor was going to be a shadier,
more untrustworthy figure, along the lines
of Odenkirk's most famous role as criminal
lawyer Saul Goodman in Breaking Bad and its
prequel Better Call Saul.
However, Winston changed significantly during
Brad Bird's rewrites and recording sessions
with Odenkirk, becoming a more 'innocent',
'positive and upbeat' guy.
Although Incredibles 2 picks up right where
the first film left off, at one point, Brad
Bird did briefly consider aging up the Parrs
and showing them at completely different stages
in their lives, in line with the 14 years
that have passed since the original movie.
But, ultimately, Bird was more keen on following
the example set by The Simpsons which he used
to work on, as he wanted to further explore
the special insight and perspectives that
each character had on their particular period
of life and he also just wasn't 'interested
in a college-age Jack-Jack'.
And I'm so glad he made that decision as seeing
an incredibly super-powered baby was one of
my favourite parts of the movie.
Brad Bird came up with the core idea for Incredibles
2, in other words its mum-and-dad role reversal
and its focus on Jack-Jack's powers, around
the time he finished the original movie.
However, numerous other ideas for the remaining
storyline were initially considered.
The first plot that was pitched, and which
was greenlit by Pixar, involved Artificial
Intelligence.
The crew started working on this, but Bird
had to abandon it when he realised it just
didn't work.
In fact, Bird has said his scrapped A.I.
idea could make its way into another movie,
so he hasn't yet given any further details
on it.
Of course, AI was already featured in the
first movie via the Omnidroid.
Bird then tried another story which featured
the Parrs enjoying the showbiz spotlight.
Speaking to CinemaBlend, the filmmakers explained
that the stakes in this story just weren't
high enough to create good drama and, that
it made the family seem shallow.
Eventually at an internal Pixar screening,
it was Finding Nemo director Andrew Stanton
who suggested that, given Helen's reluctance
to rejoin the world of supers in the first
film, the sequel needed to provide 'a really
strong reason for her to do that' and that
led to the idea that Elastigirl should be
the poster person for legalising supers which,
combined with the introduction of a brand
new villain the Screenslaver, would properly
up the stakes for the new movie.
By the way, the gorgeous Art of Incredibles
2 hardback book also has some cool concept
art of outtakes from the movie, including
a story where the Parr family travel to an
icy, frozen land.
And there's an intriguing shot of Bob frozen
under a thick layer of ice, so I'm thinking
this story might have involved Helen and the
family travelling there to rescue him, though
that might have felt a bit too similar to
the first movie.
There are also some very interesting characters
that were deleted from Incredibles 2 including
Frozone's wife Honey and I'll reveal all the
details in my next video.
I'll link to it here and in the video description
as soon as it's ready.
Now, are there any of these deleted scenes
or stories you would like to have seen in
the movie?
And what was your favourite moment in the
finished film?
Be sure to comment and subscribe for a chance
to win an awesome Incredibles Funko Pop.
Tap left to check out the top 30 easter eggs
you might have missed in Incredibles 2 or
tap right for my full Pixar playlist where
I explain all of Jack-Jack's 17 powers!
And tap the bell to get all my new videos
as soon as I upload them.
If you enjoyed this video, a thumbs-up is
always appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!